we're ready Hello
everyone. Hope
your rain event has been great.
My name is Gu Yu. I am a senior solutions
architect supporting
the AWS Social responsibility
and Impact modernization.
Hi everyone, I'm Nathan Pathak. I'm a technical
account manager at AWS
and part of the sustainability team for almost 2
years now.
And thank you so much
for joining our session on sustainable
computing for climate solutions.
In today's session, we're going to first of all
talk about climate challenges
and the complexity of solving climate
challenges.
We're also going to talk about why HPC
or high performance computing is important
in solving climate challenges.
After that, we'll dive a little bit deeper
into some patterns in terms of
sustainable HPC workload
and then followed up with a case study from
the University of Oxford
to see how they're applying some of these
practices into their HPC
workload.
Then we'll summarize with some next steps.
But before we get started,
by show of hands, how many of
you have been impacted
by climate change over the past few
years?
Looks like everyone has been impacted.
All right, Nitin, I saw that you got
impacted.
Can you share your experience and
how it felt like and what did you have
to do to adapt?
Certainly, so I live in a part of India.
It's called New Delhi, and every winter
we have a concern that when the temperature starts
dipping. There's a lot of smog
in the air,
so it's low visibility, dusty
particles, and the AQIs get really high.
The pollution gets really high,
so we have to live with
air purifiers all the time, and it becomes problematic.
People have problems with breathing,
breathing, and they're going outside. So this becomes a
challenge almost every year, and we
hope,
we hope there's some solution for that.
Yeah, and it probably doesn't help with the health equity
and different types of socioeconomics
it doesn't. It certainly doesn't.
I'm sure some of you are experiencing
some of the similar
challenges as well
with climate challenge.
We're having more and more extreme weather
events. For example, our summers are getting
hotter and lasting longer,
which not only reduces yields
for major crops,
but also but also leads to
death. Our
hurricane is lasting longer and
intensifies faster,
which makes it very difficult for fast
disaster recovery efforts.
In some parts of the world,
increased precipitation leads to
flooding.
In other parts of the world, decreased
precipitation leads to drought,
which impacts food security.
And now we have wildfire.
Wildfire season is lasting longer
and
it's leading to damages
that's not only in property but
also leads to air pollution.
I have the opportunity to work with many
customers that are tackling some of these
challenges.
At AWS Social Responsibility
and Impact,
our vision is to improve lives
every day.
And we believe that cloud and AI
technologies are powerful
tools
to help
build solutions that tackle some
of these challenges in health,
education, and climate.
But building climate challenge,
building climate solutions is
difficult.
In fact,
climate challenge is very complex
because first of all,
The climate system itself is
complex.
As we know, there are different components
in the
climate system. We have the atmosphere
with the air.
We have the hydrosphere with the water, the
lake, the ocean.
We have the cryosphere with the ice.
We have the lithosphere, the land,
and we have the biosphere, the living beings,
we are part of it.
And these 5 components interact
with each other in very complex
ways which makes it very difficult
to understand the impact
of any intervention.
Apart from the complex climate
system, we also have a very
complex human society.
This is not just socioeconomic,
political, cultural, and also
because climate change is a global
issue. Communities,
regions are impacted very
differently.
So there are also disagreements in terms
of the best way to adapt and mitigate.
And then the urgency makes
solving climate challenges
even more difficult because now
we have to evaluate the
long-term and short-term trade-offs.
Scientists tell us that we have a limited
window to make unprecedented
headway in order to keep our
global temperature rise to below
1.5 °C.
And as we are taking action now,
we also have to evaluate the
impacts in the long term
to make sure that our efforts are
sustainable.
The good news is that we are making
progress. We're
making our buildings.
Greener.
We're taking more into consideration of
sustainable building practices
from building design,
the type of materials that we're using
to build our buildings,
the type of energy we're using
and when and how we're using the
energy. When
it comes to energy,
we're using more renewable energy,
wind, solar,
geothermal, hydro, and more.
When it comes to food supply,
we're applying more sustainable agriculture
practices
so that we can reduce water waste
as well as improve soil
health.
And we're also electrifying our
transportation sector so that
we can reduce the emissions from harmful,
reduce the harmful emissions from
conventional combustion engine.
In order for all this to work effectively,
we need technology.
Technology enables and accelerates
climate solutions.
Now, as solutions architect or
researcher or innovator,
as we are translating into
climate challenge
into kind of technical requirements,
we really need our technology staff
to do 3 things
and do and do 3 things very well.
First of all, in terms of data.
Data is important in
any system,
but it's extremely important
in Building a climate solution
because, as we mentioned earlier,
climate system is extremely complex.
So in order to understand the complex system,
we need data from
different sources.
So this could be data from supply
chain data to understand carbon footprint.
This could be satellite imagery to
understand vegetation index.
This could also be
the sound of the ocean to understand
ocean noise pollution, right?
So these data
needs to come from various sources and
some of them can be very large.
But the ability to acquire
high value
is extremely important.
And secondly, we need a storage
option, a storage solution
and because our data is from
different types of sources and can be very
large, our storage needs to
be able to accommodate that.
And also because these data can be
large, we also need to be able to retrieve
the data easily and efficiently
as well.
So now we have the data and we
store the data.
Now we can actually understand the patterns
behind the data. So the third
component is compute.
We need our technology stack to be
able to.
Do large scale data processing,
simulation
so that we can understand the patterns
behind the data.
And I hear that Newton has some recommendations.
And we have, we have a technology stack
that can help you
to build solutions
towards finding the solutions for
your climate problem.
Have you heard of high performance computing, a show of hands,
and have you been using it?
Certainly
it is an amazing and efficient way of
how technology can interact with one another
in order to provide us an infrastructure
and a setup that will help us conduct
our research, that will give you solutions
for complex problems and
specifically problems related to climate research.
I've been an HPC admin myself for a large
part of my career.
And I know this is extremely useful.
However,
there's one problem with it.
An HPC grid usually consists of hundreds
and hundreds of servers.
That would mean
it can consume loads of energy.
Setting this up is never easy.
Even though it is the right tool set for our solution,
it might not be the easiest and the most
sustainable way to do it in
an on-premises setup.
Thus,
there needs to be a fine.
That's where AWS comes in and
sees how it can help you for the next one.
When it comes to sustainability,
we also follow the shared responsibility
model.
You might also, you might already be familiar
with the shared responsibility model of security,
but in terms of sustainability,
AWS is responsible for
sustainability of the cloud.
So that means our global infrastructure, including
our data center,
our electricity supply,
servers, cooling, building materials,
and so forth.
Customers, you
are responsible for sustainability
in the cloud,
so that's your workloads, right.
Region selection,
how you're using your data,
how you're storing your data.
And if you're working on machine learning workloads,
that could also mean
what type of model you're choosing,
how you're building your model,
how you're deploying your model and
writing your inferences and scaling
your model.
Now diving a little bit deeper into sustainability
of the cloud and our AWS global
infrastructure.
And then AWS
continues to relentlessly
innovate our infrastructure to
build the most secure,
performing, resilient and sustainable
cloud
for our customers worldwide.
We have 120 available zones
in 245 countries and
territories
across 38 geographic
regions.
And according to an Accenture study,
Workloads on AWS is up
to 4.1 times
more efficient than on premises.
How we're able to achieve that is through
our data center
design. Which is
enhanced for
tomorrow's AI tech uh AI workloads.
So one way we evaluate data center
efficiency is to use this metric
called power usage effectiveness
or PUE.
And the PUE,
a lower POE indicates a more efficient,
uh, data center and a POE
one is perfect.
So as you can see, our HBS
global infrastructure have a
POE of 1.15 which
outperforms on-premises average
as well as public cloud industry
standard.
We did that through optimizing our data
center design
with 46%
reduced mechanical energy as well
as 35% less embodied
carbon in the concrete that we use.
And with that,
by just bringing your workloads
to AWS you are already benefiting
from the carbon reduction.
And depending on the region where your workloads
are running, uh, you will receive
different
benefits in terms of energy efficiency
and by optimizing your workloads
on AWS, which Nain we'll talk
about in a little bit,
you will be reducing carbon footprint
even more.
So, I want to watch.
Now AWS has been playing its part in
order to make things more efficient for you, the infrastructure
more efficient for you by various means.
Now, we also don't leave it there.
We'll provide you enough material so how you can
improvise your, improve your workloads
and go buy it.
And this thing you might have heard of your solution architects,
and it's a very common thing from AWVL arched framework.
It was built on 5 major principles,
operational excellence,
performance efficiency, reliability, security,
and cost efficiency.
When we added the sustainability pillar
to it in 2021,
our focus was to have a standard framework
which our users can utilize and
implement the same strategies to their workload,
to the architecture, to continue to improve
and reduce their overall carbon emissions.
Then when we go around following these practices,
reviewing our workloads against these
best practices, against these pillars, we are able
to identify and improve
our overall workload setup.
The sustainability best practices lie
around these six foundational pillars
which we call the cornerstone for any of
the any of the architecture which we will define
for you. So when we are thinking about sustainability
of our workloads, we'll talk about the region
selection, alignment to demand, data,
hardware and services,
our software and architecture, and most importantly,
process and culture. That is what we do within
ourselves. In addition to that, we
also have a customer carbon footprint tool.
We have been using our billing and billing dashboard
regularly
to visualize how much, how much costs are ongoing.
This also helps you to get a
reflection of where your carbon
emissions are also going for your workloads. This
will give you a breakdown based on the regions
and the services and overall usage
per account so that you will have clarity
of the kind of
things you have done for your carbon emissions and where is it going
and what you probably should consider in
order to go forward, have a proper measuring and
reporting tool.
Now with this we have this ability
to visualize what we have.
Now we go back to the HPC and go back
to how AWS can help you
get to a sustainable high performance computing
setup, and the building blocks
for sustainable high performance computing setups
are as follows.
I'm just showcasing this divided into three common
layers. The first one being the cohort,
the the the framework, something
where the foundation lies, which is
where the storage will be in terms of file systems
and where.
Our network will be. So we have
Amazon FSX for luster,
for luster-based computing,
and elastic fabric adapter that will help you for
high fast speed network
interface for your HPC cluster.
Then we'll go for the compute and our scheduling
services, and we have options of AWS
Pallel cluster, AWS batch,
and AWS parallel computing Service.
I'll dig a big deep dive. I'll
do a deep dive down on this to
get you where we can utilize each of these. And
finally, how do we visualize, how do we interact with the
system? And we have the Amazon DCV
and we have the
research and engineering studio on AWS
that can be utilized for you to visualize
and work with your workflows.
Now we go back to the, the, the aspects
which Guy spoke about, the key areas and avenues
that we want to
focus on as we build solutions
on for for our climate research.
The first one is data.
And data is pivotal for any kind of research, specifically
when we are doing climate research.
We need a lot of data from various sources
that can be,
that can give us the most accurate results.
And if that data is not good
for us, it will give us, it will not give
us good enough results.
It will be any kind, it will be
stored across coming from various sources and
it will be populated in various places,
and we need to utilize the same.
There's one concern with this.
The data which we might need for research
will be in exabytes and exabytes overall,
and that will cost emission. Storing all
that data will cost emission.
That means we will have our storage resources
consuming all these data stored coming from
various sources, storing
our storage systems and using it over
and over again.
Another aspect to this is the data transfer.
Most of the customers we have worked with who
want to reduce their carbon emissions tend to
neglect the emissions
coming from data transfer from one
source to source to a destination.
That's a key aspect of carbon emissions which is going around,
and we need to reduce the same.
The key thing which will come out from there is
that the data is reusable,
and we need to find out ways
on how to do it.
Well, AWS has found one way of how to do it for
you. By creating an open
data on AWS.
Now this platform has
data coming from various sources, research facilities,
various types of research, be it nonprofit
organizations, scientific organizations, multiple places
correlated to the data in a single place, and using
AWS data exchange, you have access to them.
Along with that, one good thing comes over there,
it is ready to use on the fly. You don't
need to download it to your
or transfer it to your storage
accesses, your storage devices. You don't
need to move it to your SD buckets. You can keep it
there, so the major chunk of data is
just available. You can start to use it on the
fly, use it for reset purposes,
and get on the next, get on with your development
part. So once we have the data
part sorted,
next is the storage.
While we conduct our research,
we will require file systems and we'll also require a lot
of artifacts which will develop out or spin out
from our research
and how do we manage this.
As those artifacts will again be of
a huge volume, we need to first identify
data access patterns,
and we need to ensure that
we are able to
reduce our usage in that front as
well. While we're using
Amazon S3.
We specify that there
are life cycle policies that we can certainly utilize.
Now these life cycle policies help in
order to move data from
used very frequently
to not used at all.
And by this, and even from there further
deleting them when there's something that is not being used.
Now understanding this aspect that
considering the raw data, the source data is available for
us. The computers can be
readily available for us.
We don't necessarily have to store
unnecessary data, and we can get rid of it to
ensure that we are keeping our costs
in check and keeping our ambitions in check as well.
Next part is the file system.
Now for an on-premises high performance
computing setup,
we require a file system which is very
fast, very efficient, and we have to
replicate something similar for
for our AW services as well.
And that's where Amazon FSX for Luster came
into the picture.
It provides great benefits such as intelligent tiering,
which moves data from one type of storage
tier to another. It will help you to reduce your emissions.
It will also help us with life cycle management, automated
lifecycle management, so that you can clean up data
as well. And
the data archival along with the integration
with S3 will help you move your artifacts in the
right place, right position as well.
Overall, when it combines together.
Amazon Amazon FSS for
Luster provides high performance file
system for your high performance computing.
And can reduce your storage footprint as
compared to standard data center by up to 50%.
That's a huge differentiation in
terms of sustainability, in terms of
benefiting from carbon emission efficiency.
And the final component, compute.
Now this is where AWS has been really
Doing a lot of innovation and making strides
on how we can benefit the power of cloud
in order to conduct the research for high performance
computing. Like I said, a normal cluster
will take up to hundreds
of servers at least to get started for various workloads.
We have, I spoke about three solutions. We'll
start with this AWS parallel cluster.
Now if you're coming from an HPC background and you
have your open MP and MPI-based workloads
and you want to replicate the same
on cloud,
this is a good starting place for you.
It will provide you the scheduler that will
be integrating that will integrate
with our auto scaling mechanism with
our clusters with our with our in servers
and instances that can scale up and scale down
based on requirements,
and we have seen that by using AWS
parallel cluster.
It can reduce carbon
carbon footprint by up to 57%
from a standard HPC
workloads. So that means it is efficient.
It integrates well with AW services such as
Luster, EC2,
EFA, and
NICE DCV for visualization purposes and
gives you a good platform for you to conduct a
research. If you already have your workloads already
built for on premises, and just
bring them on the fly and start using them.
The next part is the AWS batch.
An AWS batch can be extremely efficient for your
high performance computing scheduling system,
provided if you have
loosely covered workloads or your workloads are already
on containers or you're building something on containers,
and you want to run them on a parallel computing part.
This will give you a provision of having a job schedule
that will reduce,
will do the scheduling part itself,
and it will also help in reduction of compute
time by up to 60%.
And as we reduce the compute time, we will be
able to see it also the resources
are used for a shorter period of time. That means your efficiency
increases in terms of your emissions.
And the last one.
Let's say you're just getting started. You're just a
researcher who has not have any experience
of any kind of HPC or a container workload,
and you want to get started towards
building a carbon intelligence orchestration system.
In this scenario,
AWS parallel computing system
service can be really useful for you as it does
all the heavy lifting work for itself. You don't have
to worry about what kind of computer you want to keep in place.
It will not have to worry about how you will do scheduling.
You just build your job, build your research,
uh, research algorithm your codes and stuff, and it
will just be deployed from the best
usage in the most efficient way
that will help reduce your wait time. It will,
it will be easily, easy to set up and
prioritize. You can just focus towards your research
and not worry about the infrastructure part.
So all the, all of these combined will give you a
core area
of the compute platform that can be utilized
for a research part.
Next, we'll talk about the instances.
AWS has been working a lot on the
instances which are focused towards high performance
computing and accelerated computing aspects. We
have instances which are HPC optimized, that
will be efficient while we are conducting
research and running our jobs for HPC-based
setup. And also for accelerated computing
where we might require graphical intensive workloads
as well
where like an example which we'll probably show
we'll have that showcase as well where graphical
based results needs to be
also managed so we have
instances which are developed for the same as well.
Guy initially spoke about sustainability of the cloud,
and AWS has been doing a lot of work
on this fronts.
When it comes to efficient silicon,
and that means the chip design, we come from the bottom
up, we start working on the chip
design aspect as well,
so where we can
improve on that.
And
our three key chips which have been
utilized, one Graviton, which might have
been the most common for any compute purposes,
they're extremely power efficient. They're up to 60%
more power efficient
than a standard
EC-2 of a similar,
similar family.
For a lot of our research
we require model training, model optimization,
and for that we have our inferentia
and cranium,
and inferentia was specifically built
for
being more giving you better performance
per the power per watt
in terms of the utilization. That
means and as we grow to newer models
of influentia as we have gone to infringentia 2,
influential 3.
It keeps improving in terms
of the power efficiency for
each and every time it conducts
any inference and optimization,
and tranium for any training purposes, it
can give up to 25% better energy efficiency
than any standard easy to instance of the same
kind. And as we keep developing a newer
version, the focus always remains how
tranium can be used for training your
models at a faster pace and be
more efficient pace as well.
Now I spoke about all these materials. Now how will
it look like when you are really building
it all into a play?
How all of this will come together?
I'll give you a sam
few sample diagrams if you, in case in any
of these three fronts you want to utilize AWS
parallel cluster, AWS
batch, or AWS
uh parallel computing service. Any of, in
any of these scenario.
And architecture will look something like this.
Uh, let's say that you are just a res you are a researcher
who's conducting climate research
and you want to utilize parallels, so that
means you already have jobs which are from HPC based
from open MP or MP based jobs.
Over here you require a nice DCV setup,
so that's something for your visualization perspectives, how
it will interact with your head node and your queue.
You will have auto scaling. You will create queues
for your requirements based on, it might be a high
memory queue or a GPU-based queue or a compute-based
queue and set this up in your VPC
and over there, FSX Fluster will be your file system
interacting with your.
Various compute nodes
and you will be able to interact with this and
have the
and run run and schedule your jobs.
The one benefit of pilot trust is, like I
said, if you want to manage things yourself, if you
want to identify which kind of
computer resources you want to keep,
this gives you a flexibility of choosing those resources.
So if you have a more customized job which requires specific
understanding which you want to do, take
control in your hand, you can utilize parallel
cryst in that scenario.
Next we go to AW's batch, and this,
like I mentioned, is going to be a similar setup. The
only difference is if you have more loosely coupled
or container-based workloads which will
run in parallel.
AWS batch will be a solution for you as
you can start to run your containers, deploy them,
and they will run in parallel
across
for these various queues and do the
work for you. The job scheduling part will be managed
by AWS batch,
so the scheduling part is completed. Your only
part is running the jobs and having this set up there
again. You have an option of choosing what
kind of instances you would like on the back end.
So that's
one more control you will have in your hand.
And the third part is the AWS parallel computing
service, and this is where we need the least operational
overhead altogether.
We are only focusing on submitting our jobs
and letting them work on the back end, so all the
part of managing the cluster,
managing the compute resources, managing any kind
of resources will be handled by AWS and Parallel
Computing Service,
and you will be only focused on developing your job
codes, developing your solutions and building
them same, so you will get the information in,
get it done, and once you have the artifacts ready, you're
happy to go
in this. So this is what AWS
HPC architectures could look like,
and now we'll take a look at
what it could lead, what kind of
research it could facilitate, and for this
we have an example of a case study
where
we'll you will talk about how University of Oxford
has been benefiting towards this.
Thank you. So,
I'm going to tell you a story.
The story starts in the Indo-Gadantic
region, so that's in the India,
Pakistan, and Bangladesh
area. Air pollution
is a big problem.
Li Tian will tell you all about it.
In fact,
this is one of the most polluted
areas globally,
with pollution level exceeding the
WHOO standard by up to 10
times.
And that leads to
over 2 million premature deaths annually.
But because
There is no precise data in terms
of where the pollution sources are.
The efforts to address this
crisis has been hindered for decades.
One of the main pollution sources is
a brick kiln.
Brick kilns are kilns that are
used to make bricks,
and in the process of making bricks,
the kilns emit dangerous
pollutants such as carbon dioxide
and particulate matters.
And because of the rapid rise
of real
estate industry.
There has been a lot more vehicles
that have been built, and a lot of them are operating.
Without without regulation.
Now, enters APA
or the Air Pollution Asset
Level detection,
which is a research
project from the Smith School of Enterprise
and Environment at the University of Oxford.
So APA believes
that clean air is a fundamental
human right.
They, they
envision
communities that are free from.
Air pollution and they believe that
clean air should be prioritized for the
current and future generations.
So how they plan to do that is
they want to detect all the bras
in the Indoggenic region.
And that covers 1.5 million
square kilometers of land.
And after detecting all of them, they
want to create a map,
an interactive dashboard
so that communities can understand.
Where they are and so that they
can make more data-driven decisions.
Now for researchers, when you start
working on the research,
the first step is to start looking
at some of the data and then maybe
use the local machine to run
some analysis, do some geospatial data
processing, run uh build some machine learning
models.
As they are working on this project, they realized
that local machines couldn't handle the scale
of data storage,
processing, and machine
learning workloads
because they are working with millions of
data points from different types of
data sources.
Now the main data that you're, they're using
are satellite imageries.
They choose satellite imagery because
satellites offer consistent
wide area and historical Earth
observations so that it can help them to
understand the region that they are studying.
And there are different types of satellite imageries.
Um, a lot of them are
publicly available such as the Sentinel
2 and Lancesat
projects. There are also some sala
imageries that are, uh,
require, uh, that are commercially
available.
There's also the difference between low
low resolution satellite imagery
and high resolution satellite imagery.
So if we're looking at brake hills with
low resolution versus high resolution,
you see the clear difference.
If we're looking at the ones that are towards
your right, those are the ones with
lower resolution at 10 m resolution.
Brake hills look like an orange
blob.
You're with a bunch of pixels.
You probably wouldn't be able to
confidently say that this is a
brick hill. This, you can just say
this is might be an orange oval
object, right?
Versus if you're looking at the higher resolution
satellite imagery on the left
at the 0.5 m resolution,
you can confidently say this is the Brick
hill. But
the higher resolution satellite imagery
can be expensive.
So what the researchers did is they started
out with
low resolution imagery
using Sentinel 2.
So they built a random forest classification
model to identify
orange oval
objects
and here is one
object being identified.
So this is the potential
bra kill. s
As we know, because for the low resolution
satellite imageries, we cannot confidently
say that this is actual a brick kiln.
The result is they identified
31,000 brick kilns in Pakistan,
which is
a lot more than how many there actually
are. So they understand that there are
a lot of false positives.
But what they then did is to
use these identified.
Objects
as
potential brake hills for
further analysis.
They then acquired the sala imageries
for only those areas that are identified
and then.
Acquire the right high resolution imageries
and then um run a high
resolution workflow
to
understand the locations
of the exact
uh exact uh bra hills.
So here they are annotating
uh the brakis using uh
with high resolution satellite imagery
and then run computer vision models in order
to identify where the brake kilns actually
are. Now
with that, they are able to
create an interactive
map of where all the brake hills are
in the region.
As well as some other pollution sources
such as boiler,
steel, and
and primary
energy generation sources such as coal, fossil
fuel, and more.
And if you are clicking into each
of the assets, you will be able to
understand also
the um
the the actual
impact of these pollution sources
and this really helps the community to
understand their areas
better.
And they are expanding their work in Africa as
well to help communities
there
to make data-driven decisions.
So tying this back to
some of the best practices and patterns
that Newton has shared with us before.
For the APA solution,
in terms of data, they use open data
as the foundation of their analysis.
They use Sentinel 2
from the open data registry for
uh
so that they don't have to store the data.
And then storage, the analyze
the
data access pattern and only store
the data that's needed.
And in terms of compute,
they run their low resolution workflow
and high resolution workflow on
EC2,
but they understand that for different types
of workflows they require
different resources. For example, the low
resolution work. Flow will require
more compute and the high
high resolution workflow will require
more memory, so they are optimizing,
they choose their EC2 instances
accordingly in order to use the
right tool for the job.
As a result,
they were able to process 1.2
million satellite imageries
and saved
over 17,000 compute hours.
With up to 80% reduction in
infrastructure costs as well as 90%
reduction in monitoring time and task
run time.
Solomon, the machine learning and
deep learning specialist has said,
we started with a social goal
and AWS was a means
to reach that goal.
So what's next for the APEC group is that
as you already saw, they are expanding their work
in the Africa region to help the
communities there to understand air pollution
problems better as well.
They also launched a volunteer program.
Along with an app
for the on the ground uh pollution
reporting.
That will help them to capture additional data
points to create more comprehensive
map of pollution sources.
And they are also looking to leverage additional
AWS services such as Bedrock
uh for geospatial foundation models.
So now we're going to talk about
next steps, a little bit of summary, Nin.
Absolutely. Sure.
Now we'll talk about the things that we learned,
what we have key takeaways from this.
First of all,
high performance computing doesn't
require those huge data centers
powered by thermal energy.
We can get it done sustainably.
We have ways and means for it and utilize.
If that's a concern that how you will set up
and most importantly, the speed of it.
You don't need to wait to get your
high performance computing clusters up
and running.
You can get it done
very quickly in a matter of minutes,
get it up for you, and start with your
research. That's something very useful for you.
The next part is identifying the
data sources and data transfers.
We don't have to keep moving data
from one source to another. We don't have to worry about storing
all the data which we need for our research at
various places. We don't have to worry about those costs.
We don't have to worry about those emissions.
We have everything in a single place that we can just
directly go ahead and use, utilize the scalability
and the flexibility the cloud has to offer, that AWS
has to offer.
The Third thing is understand the data access pattern,
the requirements, what kind of file system you
will require for your computing cluster.
It is important to have that set up
in place.
It might not be the case that a shared file system, a standard
NFS-based file system like an EFS, might
be the best solution. We need faster solutions.
We have solutions for them. If you need a slower
solution, there are things available which are more effective
for you. Choose and identify the same.
You have the ability and flexibility to manage that
on your own.
And the performance requirement. What kind of compute
do you want to do and how much effort do you
want to do in order to manage that cluster for
yourself? Add these elements together
and finally choosing the right tool for the job.
Does your workload workload require a good
stereographic setup for your 3D imagery
process as well?
If you that's a, that's a requirement, certainly
utilize nice DCB and Research Engineering studio
for AWS in that capacity.
If using an HPC accelerated
instance will be the right solution for
you, utilize parallel cluster and add it
over there.
And finally, if you just want,
don't want to add to any of these elements, utilize
ABS parallel computing service.
Understand your requirements. What is the goal for
you? What's your business use case? When do you want to achieve
it? What's the speed and cost
consideration comes into the picture.
Analyze all of them.
And you can find out the solutions exist
and you can easily go in and also there's
an ability for you to just try out these
things as well and which works fits best
for you and try to start using the same as
well. And for that we have
a few more resources that can be helpful.
For example,
for example, we have.
You. To
deliver to you something
that you can rely on and then ultimately
verify, which is why people.
verification. She's
representing the review.
This is a new initiative that we're
to showcase how we're using AI to
help solve humanity's most pressing
problems.
If you want to learn more about how our
customers are doing so, check out this page.
And last but not the least,
level up your skills on AWS Skills
Builder.
So this is a great place for you to build your
cloud and AI skills your
way at your own pace.
And
if you can please complete
the session survey in your application,
and we'll really appreciate that and thank you
so much for joining our session.
And if you have any questions.
If you have any questions, we'll be happy to answer you and
we're helping you for the same. Thank you so much for attending.
Thank you.